everyone's going to try to stop you at  some level  everybody is going to say by the way  this is what the language sounds like i  have very good friends they'll call me  they'll say things like this  hey pat  i found your stories do you think it's  healthy that you're working the way  you're working  what do you mean well bro look man i  mean everybody knows how much money you  have right now we don't know exactly but  we know you have a lot of money why like  what how many more hundreds of million  like what do you what's going on bro you  know i don't know if this is like some  stuff like it's hypomanic adhd issue  stuff like you know what i'm saying like  maybe it's like kind of settled down a  little bit  and they give this speech and i'm like  very each man awesome it's great not for  me  it's not the life i signed up for